e aí
e quem lhe deu o nome
e no olhar de quem você se reconheceu o
primeiro quantas canetas escrever uma
história sobre você eu você todos nós só
existimos pelos olhos dos outros esses
grandes outros de que fala tanto a
psicanálise
e eu existo porque escutei muitas
histórias sobre mim mesma histórias de
adultos poderosos da minha infância meu
pai minha mãe minha professora a
benzedeira o andarilho o tocador de
sinos todos eles a palavra de todos eles
me constituiu e eu continuo ainda hoje
atualizando história sobre mim eu
continuo ainda hoje me procurando no
olhar do outro para me reconhecer é
também pelas histórias desses outros que
eu me constitui menina e depois mulher
esses outros e um me dizendo que meninas
precisam ajudar nas tarefas domésticas
que não podem ser desbloqueadas e que
tem que se dar ao respeito que mulher
bem-sucedida tem que ter um marido e de
preferência filhos e uma casa para
cuidar depois o meu irmão um ano
é o que eu tive que aprender a ser
menino e depois ele se tornou homem
crescemos juntos dividimos a mesma
escola a mesma casa os mesmos pais a
mesma pobreza mas o mundo tinha
expectativas muito diferentes sobre nós
ser menino e ser menina é então uma
realidade fabricada fabricada no
discurso são construções culturais
arbitrárias portanto o que eu tenho de
real é um corpo biológico que é
diferente do corpo dos meninos agora
como eu devo me comportar com esse corpo
são construções culturais a essas
convenções deus se o número nome de
gênero um dia convenceu não se que as
coisas seriam de um jeito e não de outro
naturalizou se narrar
a medicina na política na arte na
educação sobre os papéis sociais de
homens e de mulheres
e a escritora nigeriana chimamanda em
sua fabulosa palestra o perigo da
história única afirma que é importante
termos acesso a muitas narrativas
inclusive sobre nós mesmos elas essas
narrativas vão criando a nossa
capacidade de compreender a realidade
vão esvaziando aquela tentação que temos
de explicar fenômenos complexos com uma
única e grande narrativa quando temos
acesso a muitas histórias nós não nos
satisfazemos mais com generalizações do
tipo as mulheres são mais inseguras os
homens são mais assertivos as mulheres
são mais sentimentais os homens são mais
racionais ter acesso a muitas narrativas
é uma maneira de educar o nosso olhar
para a complexidade da vida
quem nos educa para não sermos
preconceituosos nos educa contra a
cultura do holocausto
o segundo a organização mundial da saúde
o brasil ocupa a vergonhosa quinta
posição mundial de taxas de feminicídio
e os números só crescem infelizmente o
feminicídio é um crime hediondo cometido
contra as meninas e as mulheres pela sua
condição de gênero ou seja meninas e
mulheres morrem por que possivelmente
não se ajustam aquilo que é esperado
delas pelos homens que as matam ou seja
que não fico em casa que não usam não
use roupas curtas que não estudem que
não trabalha em que não argumentem que
não desobedeçam
e o atlas da violência estima que eu
corro no brasil entre 500 300 e 500 mil
estupros por ano considerando que apenas
de dez a quinze por cento dos casos são
notificados
e esses números alarmantes são retro
alimentados por narrativas que
apresentam a menina ea mulher como
objeto à disposição do prazer alheio no
meu doutorado em linguística aplicada eu
investiguei narrativas de abuso sexual
infantil e eu descobri que existe um
certo roteiro para as vítimas narrarem a
sua violência a violência sofrida para
que sejam consideradas as vítimas
autênticas se esta narrativa não conheci
dir com as expectativas sociais elas
podem ser desacreditados esses roteiros
universalizantes então podem aumentar o
sentimento de trauma e de inadequação
porque as pessoas não se reconhecem na
narrativa oficial por que acontece que
todo ser humano vive de uma forma muito
individual as suas experiências e quando
a narrativa é muito roteirizada ela pode
não ser
o seguro para organizar eventos tão
dolorosos e caóticos uma vítima
autêntica nunca pode andar sozinha à
noite não pode beber não pode usar
roupas curtas caso contrário ela está
pedindo para ser violentada uma vítima
autêntica luta com o seu agressor caso
contrário ela estará consentindo uma
vítima autêntica fica prostrada
indefinidamente caso contrário lateral
exagerada na sua narrativa
e eu tenho uma coluna em um jornal local
em que público contos e crônicas e eu
recebo inúmeras mensagens de pessoas que
me propõe temas e histórias isso me
comove porque mostra que as pessoas têm
necessidade de se enxergarem nas
histórias de terem as suas experiências
legítimas uma leitora me escreveu certa
vez dizendo que ela precisava se
enxergar em um texto que ela precisava
se sentir uma mãe viável uma mãe
possível ocorre que essa mulher foi mãe
na adolescência e o companheiro dela ela
extremamente ciumento não permitia que
ela trabalhasse e que ela estudasse
ficou anos nessa relação até que
conseguiu sair e foi buscar a sua
autonomia enquanto isso o filho ficou
com o pai essa mãe pagou pensão comprou
material escolar
de roupas visitava criança mas nada
disso foi suficiente ela ficou condenada
pela sociedade com uma mãe que abandonou
o filho como a mãe não suficiente o
homem ele tem toda a licença para ir
para o mundo e não precisa se explicar
muito e não precisa sentir culpa por que
a sociedade só consegue aceitar quando é
a mulher a ficar em casa e cuidar dos
filhos e isso são concepções de gênero
em ação contará sua história então foi
uma espécie de redenção contar a sua
história deu existência a ela restaurou
a sua dignidade de mãe clarice lispector
disse certa vez que escrever é também
abençoar uma vida que não foi abençoada
e as narrativas organizam as nossas
experiências e nos ajudam a lidar com os
absurdos da vida são recursos para
construir e reconstruir a realidade ea
realidade ela é sempre uma disputa de
narrativas por isso contar histórias é
exercer poder e é por isso que os
diferentes feminismos são tão cruciais
para ampliar mas o nosso repertório de
narrativas as narrativas feministas dão
voz às mulheres para que ensinarem a
partir dos seus lugares de fala os
feminismos desafio justamente as versões
universalizantes da realidade desafiam
os narradores que historicamente tiveram
a caneta na mão e a caneta assim como
membro masculino são símbolos e
instrumentos de poder
se você mesmos então nos libertam da
grande narrativa sobre o papel da mulher
e do homem na sociedade são uma
alternativa a paternidade mística da
criação são uma alternativa às
representações masculinas sobre as
mulheres tem um ditado africano que diz
que os caçadores são sempre
bem-sucedidos porque os leões não podem
contar a sua versão da história
historicamente a mulher é narrada pelo
homem e há portanto uma personagem
aprisionada em seus textos transformada
em uma visão perfeita de si mesma dela
frágil angelical recatada do lar magra
passiva imóvel sempre necessitada de
resgate e de proteção por outro lado as
mulheres ativas são sempre as perdidas
as mandonas asco
e as moças as bruxas as loucas é comum
na literatura masculina matou ser urina
dentro de casa fazer oposição a uma
megera fora da casa
a contar histórias aumenta a nossa
capacidade de sentir empatia pelos
outros aumenta a chance de construirmos
um mundo realmente capaz de abraçar a
diversidade e eu não uso a palavra
diferença mas diversidade porque
diferença pressupõe que existam
parâmetro a partir do qual se mede todos
os outros grupos sociais e este
parâmetro normalmente é branco
heterossexual e masculino minha filha
valentina de 9 anos é exposta a
histórias com múltiplas versões de
heroínas como as heroínas negras por
exemplo altivas corajosas orgulhosas de
sua pele e de seus birotes apresentar
personagens negras é educar o olhar
contra o racismo
e ela também tem acesso a histórias que
problematizam a heterossexualidade como
única possibilidade de viver o amor uma
vez ela me disse que tinha visto duas
moças se beijando na praça
e com a respiração suspensa perguntei a
ela o que ela tinha achado disso ela me
respondeu que tinha achado muito frio
para elas estarem na rua
é certa vez a professora da minha filha
explicou que o homem fez importantes
descobertas no último século
imediatamente ela questionou se as
mulheres não haviam feito nenhuma a
professora explicou que a expressão o
homem implicava também a mulher claro é
inegável que a lista de mulheres
importantes acaba em duas ou três porque
elas foram sistematicamente reduzidas
pelas narrativas oficiais como tendo um
cérebro menor como não tendo capacidade
de criar como naturalmente inclinados a
histeria ea loucura como tendo nascido
para o seu destino que a maternidade e a
domesticidade
e essas narrativas sustentam a
desigualdade de gênero que ainda hoje
prejudica todas as mulheres falar de
gênero é portanto desafiar essas
narrativas e reduzir as desigualdades eu
não utilizo também a palavra tolerância
porque tolerar significa me colocar em
uma posição de superioridade em relação
a outra é como dizer do alto da minha
presunção ok eu permito que você exista
mas não se espalhe vick dentro que eu
tinha no seu armário não precisa beijar
em público as palavras importam e não é
um debate frívolo e sem relevância como
linguística aplicada eu sei que a língua
não é neutra ela é um signo político ela
é um signo de poder por isso também é
tão importante que utilizemos os
feminino na língua se é pela língua que
existimos todas as pessoas não nomeadas
são apagadas
e o que é uma violência simbólica no
brasil o tema da linguagem inclusiva de
gênero é visto como uma irrelevância uma
bobagem essa recusa do feminino essa
diminuição do feminino essa anomalia da
linguagem reflete uma anomalia da
sociedade
e no belíssimo filme brasileiro
narradores de javé um povoado é ameaçado
de ter que sair da vila porque uma
represa em um daria tudo o pavor deste
povo era a possibilidade de deixar de
existir de não deixar rastro sobre a
terra assim eles têm a ideia de escrever
um livro todo se engajam ativamente
nesta tarefa como uma reação à morte
porque a gente conta histórias para
sobreviver ao horror de não ter uma
história contra o horror de desaparecer
para sempre
nós temos muitos jeitos de morrer por
isso as narrativas dos diferentes
feminismos são uma reação contra a morte
não só física mas também simbólica de
tantas mulheres ao redor do mundo que
ainda sofrem preconceito que ainda
recebem salários menores que ainda
acumulam tarefas domésticas que não
participam dos espaços de poder nem para
decidir coisas que dizem respeito ao seu
corpo ea sua vida
nós precisamos contar a nossa história
nossas múltiplas histórias a partir do
nosso lugar não divulgar colonizado e
além de contar nossas histórias
precisamos legitimar as histórias de
todas as mulheres precisamos nos
reconhecer umas nas outras precisamos de
solidariedade e não de competição os
feminismos são isso são a busca por um
equilíbrio de narrativas é devolver as
meninas e as mulheres uma autoimagem
positiva
o que significa que nós precisamos
assumir a autoria das nossas histórias
as narrativas feministas são um
manifesto contra o paraíso tirânico o
paraíso que nos exige silêncio e
submissão
e esse paraíso nos mata tem nos matado
historicamente por isso contar a nossa
história implica fugir do paraíso
implica abraçar os demônios
a nossa em conformidade nossa fome nossa
curiosidade nossa insubordinação nossa
raiva abrem espaço para uma poética
feminina
e os feminismos nos devolvem a caneta
nos devolvem o poder e devolvem a nossa
própria imagem soterrada sob as cópias
de nós mesmas obrigada
[Aplausos]